j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public consacré à cette première
dans notre histoire politique un
ministre en exercice jugé devant la Cour
de Justice de la République l'ancien
avocat Éric Dupont moriti aura 2
semaines pour se défendre devant un
tribunal formé de trois magistrats et 12
parlementaires pourquoi est-il jugé
qu'elle fait lui sont reprocher les
détails avec Cécile Sixou c'est une
image inédite un ministre en exercice et
pas n'importe lequel puisque qu'il
s'agit du garde des saau sur les bancs
de la justice éric dupontetti est
soupçonné de prise illégale d'intérêt en
d'autres termes d'avoir abusé de sa
fonction ministérielle pour régler ses
comptes avec des juges et ce dans deux
affaires où il était avocat la première
concerne trois magistrats du PNF le
parquet national financier dans une
vidéo diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux
datant d'octobre 2020 Éric Dupont
Moretti alors ministre explique
l'affaire le parquet national financier
a ordonné une
enquête secrète qui a duré 6 ans dans
laquelle on a fouillé les téléphones
portables d'une vingtaine d'avocats de
la place de Paris j'étais l'un des
avocats concerné j'ai déposé une plainte
et dès que j'ai été
nommé garde des saau j'ai retiré cette
plainte retrait de plainte mais quelques
mois plus tard le nouveau garde des saau
revient à la charge muni d' rapport qui
met en lumière des dysfonctionnements
dans cette affaire il ordonne une
enquête administrative elle conclut à
l'absence de faute les juges ne seront
pas sanctionnés même résultat dans une
deuxième affaire Édouard levraau un
autre juge est blanchi après une enquête
également demandé par le ministre les
deux hommes se connaissent bien opposés
quelques années plutôt dans une affaire
de corruption monégasque Eric Dupont
moriti se dit victime d'une vendetta des
magistrats il n'aurait pas supporté sa
nomination nation mais pour cet ancien
juge Éric Dupont Moretti joue depuis
longtemps la provocation j'ai lu
récemment tous c ces livres il a écrit
plusieurs autobiographies on n jamais si
bien servi par soi-même et il a des des
des propos sur les magistrats qui sont
extrêmement violents c'est c'est moi
j'aiécrit quelques livres qui sont
quelquefois un peu critiques sur le
fonctionnement de la justice mais il n'y
a jamais d'attaque comme ça frontal et
aussi virulente sur les sur les
magistrats s'il garde la confiance
d'Élisabeth borne l'issue de ce procès
déterminante le ministre joue son avenir
place
vendô comment juger un ministre de la
justice c'est le thème de notre débat ça
pourrait presque être un intitulé de
devoir de de philosophie on on en débat
tout de suite avec Cécile guérinbg
bonjour bienvenue vous êtesjour
professeur de droit public à
l'Université Paris Panthéon Assas Bruno
cotes bonsoir bienvenue Bruno
politologue chercheur au CNRS au cvipof
abelle Mestre bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste au Monde en charge des
dossiers justice Mathie croissant
éditoralist politique est resté à mes
côtés on va peut-être commencer par
rappeler Cécile guermbar que c'est une
première dans notre histoire jamais un
ministre en exercice n'a été jugé devant
la Cour de justice sur la République ou
même la Celle celle qui précédait la la
haute cours de justice haute cours de
justice non effectivement c'est une
première jusquel les toutes les affaires
qui elles ont été relativement peu
nombreuses qui ont été jugé par la Cour
de Justice de la République concerné des
anciens ministres ou des anciens
secrétaires d'État qui donc n'étaient
plus dans l'exercice de leur fonction
parce qu'il s'était euh mis en retrait
de même ou parce que les procédures ont
été longues parce que les procédures ont
été extrêmement longue alors
effectivement de ce fait la situation
était quand même très différente de la
situation actuelle où vous avez un
ministre en exercice qui éventuellement
pourrait répondre de ces actes devant le
Parlement et qui est mis en cause devant
une cour de justice de la République
avec toutes les difficultés qui tiennent
évidemment à l'exercice de sa fonction
évidemment Bruno cottr ce qui est
beaucoup plus fréquent dans not hisoire
politique c'est l'utilisation des Nau
conflit d'intérêt ça quand on quand on
parle de ministre en exercice c'est
l'une des thématiques qui qui revient
régulièrement comment elle pèse dans
l'opinion comment ces questions là pèse
dans l'opinion globalement pèse assez
lourd dans l'opinion l'idée que les
politiques ne seraient pas exemplaires
qui ne s'appliqueraient pas à eux-mêmes
les précepts ou les principes qu'il
proposent à l'ensemble de la à
l'ensemble de la société ça ça pèse
extrêmement lourd la question des
conflits d'intérêt va peser sans doute
beaucoup moins lourd que la question de
la corruption qui est quand même le cœur
du sujet com les Français et les
Français regardent les politiques comme
des gens qui qui bénéficient de pas
droit qui bénéficieraient de un certain
nombre de de privilèges ils sont perçus
globalement comme un peu enfermés dans
un univers de de de privilège alors on
sait que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça que c'est une image mais à la
rigueur on pourrait même considérer
qu'un ministre en exercice passant
devant une cour de justice de la
République ça vient contre cette cette
perception oui éventuellement mais c'est
vrai que l'opinion va quand même surtout
retenir que le garde d' saau devrait
normalement être lui-même totalement
exemplaire et ne devrait pas avoir à
rendre des comptes à la barre d'un
tribunal pendant l'exercice de son
mandat et c'est vrai que ça va poser
cette question va se la per tout au long
de ce tout au long de ce procès comment
comment effectivement les les électrices
les électeurs perçoivent l'idée d'un
ministre de la Justice en garde des saau
qui est lui-même à la barre d'un
tribunal ce qui est effectivement une
situation un peu paradoxale pour moi et
mes proches ce procès est une infamille
sont les premiers mots que Ker duporiti
a a prononcé devant la Cour de Justice
de la République àm vous l' AZ rencontré
le garde des saau il y a une quinzaine
de jours je crois pour un moins moins
même une diaine de jours bon voilà c'est
pas le plus important dans la question
mais c'est pas grave
euh dans quel état d'esprit vous il vous
est apparu plutôt confiant plutôt
confiant après c'est c'est sûr que pour
lui il va pas dire qu'il a peur et que
que qu'il craint le le
jugement il il tient vraiment à à à dire
qui qui pour lui il sera pas condamné
voilà il le répète et même quand on
évoque avec lui des
scénarios qui mettrai en cause sa
culpabilité ou son innocence tout de
suite il arrête il dit non mais de toute
façon voilà je suis pas coupable on me
reproche deux actes administratifs c'est
une vengeance voilà on me reproche
d'être ministre et cetera vous l'avez
senti à à fleur de peau sous tension
quand même euh à fleur de peau non mais
préparé voilà il avait l'air préparé
surtout et prêt à à à combattre et comme
s'il attendait un peu ce moment depuis
longtemps qui s'était retenu de é qu'il
a dit
d'ailleurs sa première prise de parole
en enfin il allait pouvoir se défendre
voilà euh que risque-t-il alors
évidemment on on est dans dans dans la
la fourchette haute 5 ans de prison
500000 € d'abande peine d'éigibilité
interdiction d'exercer une fonction
publique Cécile gu il faut rappeler
peut-être là aussi regarder un peu dans
le rétroviseur des décisions qui ont été
prises par la Cour de Justice de la
République c'est plutôt est-ce qu'on
dirait que c'est plutôt une cour
clémente je sais pas si le terme est on
peut employer ce termelà oui c'est une
cour qui est quand même globalement
relativement clémente hein puisqueelle a
est finalement assez peu condamné au
maximum elle a condamné à du surcis
assez fréquemment enfin dans deux cas en
l'occurrence elle a accompagné les les
condamnations de dispense de pine mais
je crois que surtout ça vient du fait
que c'est très difficile finalement pour
cette Cour de Justice de la République
de se prononcer sur des faits qui sont
souvent à mi-chemin entre entre un acte
ministériel et l'emprise du droit pénal
qui vient saisir plus ou moins bien des
actes de la fonction ministérielle alors
vous avez deux types d'affaires en fait
devant cette Cour vous avez des actes de
la criminalité ordinaire c'est-à-dire
des gens qui ont détourné du des fonds
qui ont été coupables qui se sont rendus
coupables de corruption là on peut se
demander pourquoi il y aurait une cour
particulière et non pas les juridictions
ordinaires et puis il y a des affaires
comme du pontéti ou l'affaire la garde
pour les arbitrages ou en l'affaire du
sang contaminé où là ce sont des actes
qui sont quand même très liés aux
fonctions et avec une espèce de de
jugement par le biais d'une procédure
pénale et d'un droit pénal qui n'est pas
nécessairement parfaitement adapté à ce
type d'acte Bruno cotr ce qui ce qui est
sûr c'est que la carrière politique
d'Éric dupontiti elle se joue pendant
ces ces 15 jours oui assez clairement
puisque au fond la carrière politique
d'Éric Dupont moriti a a commencé
fondamentalement lorsqu'il a été nommé
ministre alors on sait qu'il avait pris
des prises de position politique avant
mais véritablement une carrière
politique c'est le jour où il a été
nommé ministre c'est ce type de
nomination qui est faite au titre des
personnalités de la société civile qui
rentrent au gouvernement au titre de
leur compéten c'est vrai que c'est un
une personnalité extrêmement connu avant
même qu'il ne soit ministre par
l'étendue on va dire de son son talent
devant les devant les juridictions en
particulier la juridiction pénal cours
d'assise donc c'est vrai que pour lui
euh si si il était reconnu coupable ou
même si on avait des choses à lui
reprocher c'est vrai que ça marquerait
un peu la fin de son parcours politique
parce qu'on imagine mal qu'il dispose
ensuite du du du crédit du capital
politique comment disposent les les
professionnels de la politique qui
peuvent rebondir qui peuvent avoir une
période on va dire de de on va dire une
période relative disette électorale et
qui reviennent après mais lui c'est pas
du tout son profil il n'est là que parce
qu'il est RC Dupont Moretti immense
personnalité du système judiciaire
français alors on va pouvoir en débattre
mais Mathieu il faut peut-être dire que
déjà il va rester ministre tout au long
du procès oui et c'est sans doute ce qui
ajoute au caractère inédit de cette
affaire voilà un ministre de la Justice
mis en examen convoqué dans la CGR qui
va donc se rendre à l'audience tout en
conservant ses fonctions alors quelques
aménagements ont bien été prévu pour lui
hein il va y avoir des délégations de
signature il est dispensé de conseil des
ministres dispensé de séances de
questions au gouvernement on rappelle
que c'est dur à priori jusqu'au 16
novembre la 17 l'audience mais bravache
on l'a dit le garde des saau estime de
toute façon qu'il a rien approché à se
reproché dans cette affaire et qu' avait
donc aucune aucunement lieu d'envisager
pour lui une quelconque démission ni
même un retrait temporaire il jouit du
soutien du président de la République
qui l'a renommé à ce poste en
connaissance de cause quand même puisque
il a été mis en examen en 2021 si
mémoire est bonne et en 2022 quand il
s'est agit après l'éle la réélection
d'Emmanuel Macron de faire un nouveau
gouvernement ben Éric pour moriti a
était maintenu à son poste et de ce
point de vue c'est une petite révolution
dans la conduite du pouvoir qui met fin
une tradition vieille de plus de 30 ans
oui on va parler de la de la fameuse
jurisprudence bergovo bal oui alors
cette règle non écrite qui voulait qu'un
ministre mis en cause dans une affaire
judiciaire quitte le gouvernement on
rappelle que c'est pas un critère
d'empêchement mais que c'est la
tradition elle s'était imposé alors si
on est un peu hypocrite on disit que
c'était pour permettre au ministres
concernés de préparer sa défense de se
concentrer sur sa défense en fait
c'était aussi pour permettre au pouvoir
de ne de pas prêter le flan à des
soupçons d'influence ou de ou de
collusion et la règle avait le défaut de
piétiner un principe essentiel du droit
qui est la présomption d'innocence mais
politiquement ça arrangeait tout le
monde et la jurisprudence bergovois
baladure elle s'est appliqué dans plus
d'une vingtaine de cas y compris au
début du premier quinquen d'Emmanuel
Macron on se souvient quand même que
François baayrou mis en cause dans
l'affaire des emplois d'assistants
parlementaires du MoDem avait
démissionné entraînant avec lui Syvie
Goulard Marielle de Sarnez que quelques
temps paravant Richard Ferrand lui aussi
misise en cause dans une autre affaire
avait démissionné de de son poste de
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et puis tout ça c'est sérieusement
infléchi par la suite pourquoi cet
infléchissement et ben entre nous c'est
un mystère parce que Emmanuel Macron qui
s'était faitlire en premier temps une
République exemplaire n'a jamais
expliquer son revirement sur la question
alors on a le droit de changer d'avis he
après tout cette règle elle est
contestable en tout cas on peut
argumenter pour ou contre cette
jurisprudence Berg la dur mais ça n'a
pas été fait et ça donne l'impression
que les décisions se prennent au cas par
cas au fil de l'eau en gros à la tête du
client selon le poids politique et le
coût médiatique j'allais dire coût cut
plutôt que Cup voir les deux la seule
certitude aujourd'hui euh la seule règle
qui reste d'une certaine façon elle a
été rappelée par ellisabeth borne c'est
que condamnation éviction c'est quand
même bien la moindre des choses ouais je
je je rebondis sur ce que disait Bruno
cottrz tout à l'heure AB belle m sur
l'avenir politique de d'éc DUP pont
moriti est-ce que voilà effectivement
s'il est condamné par la Cour de Justice
de la République on a du mal enfin moi
j'ai du mal à l'imaginer rester en poste
au gouvernement ça c'est sûr mais est-ce
que pour autant son avenir politique
s'éteint à ce moment-là alors c'est vrai
que ça paraît invraisemblable qu'un
ministre de la Justice condamné même
avec dispense de peine euh reste en
poste parce que imaginez quand il va
rencontrer des magistrats quand il va
aller à l'audience solennelle la Cour de
cassation puisque les magistrats qui
vont juger professionnel les trois sont
de la Cour de cassation enfin c'est
impossible c'est c'est vraiment une
situation intenable après est-ce qu'il
veut se lancer en politique euh je je ne
sais pas il a été candidat des élections
ça pas était couronné de succès hein
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire euh et
puis euh la le fait qu' qui refuse de
démissionner avant son son procès
l'affaiblit finalement pourquoi parce
que il devient une une proie une prise
de choix pour les juges parlementaires
qui qui sont 12 à la CGR et qui ont
devant eux un poils lour de la macronie
comme il vient d'être appelé qui a été
confirmé deux fois par le président
alors que tout le monde parillait sur
sur sa sortie et qui pourrait se dire
bon bah voilà c'est l'occasion ou jamais
de de de de voilà de de se faire un un
poilord de la macronie donc arriver
comme ça c'est c'est quand même risqué
de sa de sa part et il dit en gros vous
voyez c'est bien pour ça que je crois ma
en mon innocence je n'ai peur de rien
même pas d'un jugement politique Mathieu
oui en même temps c'est c'estes juges
parlementaires puisquon rappelle qu'ils
sont 12 c'est ça si députés si sénateurs
dont 2 tiers à l'opposition ça le sert
aussi d'une certaine façon il est pas
mécontent que Daniel bonau puisqu'on
parle d'elle siège dans cette ségierre
parce que pour lui s s'il peut écrire
l'histoire en disant ils ont voulu se
payer un poids lourd de la macronie fa
ces affaires parce qu'il faut quand même
se dire son avenir politique est-il
compromis ça dépendra de sa volonté on
sait que c'est quelqu'un qui avait
plutôt plein de projets et pas à priori
celui de faire de la politique avant
qu'il ne soit nommeré au gouvernement
par ailleurs est-ce que son affaire va
être comprise des Français c'est quand
même loin d'être évident parce qu'on est
une affaire qui est complexe il faut le
rappeler hein il est soupçonné d'avoir
euh
euh j'allais dire d'aller vooir pris des
décisions sur des sujets de différents
qu'il avait avec des juges quand il
était avocat faut rappeler que dans les
deux cas qui lui sont reprochés c'est
les affaires qui avaient été lancées
avant sa nomination d' certaine façon
c'est sa prédécesseur Nicole Boubet qui
avait demandé que le juge Levau qui
était le juge de Monaco soit entendu par
sa hiérarchie et qui avait même s'était
demandé si c'est la direction des
services judiciaires qui s'était dit
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'on s'en
mèle et c'est la même Nicole Boubet qui
avait demandé une enquête de
fonctionnement sur le parquet national
financier c'est vraim la base de la
c'est la base et donc et donc oui et ça
faute à Éric duponti sil y en a une
c'est de ne pas s'être déporté dès son
arrivée dès sa nomination alors oui
certes il a retiré la plainte qu'il
avait déposé lui-même comme on l'a
entendu dans le reportage du début de
cette émission mais ensuite il dit ben
moi j'ai pris les les décisions que
celui que que proposaient mes services
ses adversaires dit non pas du tout il a
voulu régler ses comptes c'est ça que la
justice va devoir trancher mais c'est
c'est quand même particulièrement
complexe parce qu'on rappelle que dans
les quatre cas de magistrats qui étaient
incriminés par des enquêtes internes ou
administratives euh et ben ils ont les
quatre nonont pas ils été sanctionné
donc il ne les a pas il ne les a pas non
plus il n'a pas brisé leur carrière il
ne leur a rien arrivé donc la tête des
Français on n'est pas dans ce que
rappelait Bruno tout à l'heure de cas de
corruption quelqu'un qui pique dans la
caisse quelqu'un qui voilà c'est des des
un fonctionnement administratif qui est
quand même un peu complexe et un peu
obscur pour le profane sur sur la
jurisprudence Berga baladure Cécile
guerarne elle repose sur est-ce qu'il y
a un fondement juridique non il y en a
pas non c'est une simple pratique
politique hein d'ailleurs elle n'a pas
de elle on utilise le terme de
jurisprudence mais c'est c'est pas tout
à fait inter TER Mad tout c'est
effectivement une pratique politique
dont on s'éloigné quand même il y a eu
des des des des cas où on s'estéloignit
de cetteense n'a pas été appliqué de
façon totale totale et systématique je
crois que dans l'affaire du du ministre
de la des petites et moyennes
entreprises il n'a démissionné qu'une
fois
condamné ah oui ils' sont complètement
éloignés
sontloign avant le cas avant le cas du P
Moretti donc c'est c'est vraiment une
une pratique sur laquelle on peut tout à
fait revenir moi moi ce qui m'intéresse
dans ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est c'est cette histoire oui D qu'il y
a des parlementaires le toute la toute
toute tout l'intérêt de cette affaire va
être de savoir si les parlementaires
vont pouvoir finalement se payer un po
lour de la macronie et ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'on voit bien
combien précisément la Cour de Justice
de la République est le type d'
d'institution qui peut-être
instrumentaliser en fait à des fins
politiques qui n'ont pas grand chose à
voir avec le droit pénal alors ça on y
reviendra en détail sur le
fonctionnement de la Cour de Justice de
la République est-ce qu'il faut la
maintenir la supprimer ou pas ce sera
l'un des thèmes de notre euh débat je
voudrais revenir quand même sur c'est un
peu Ubu que Bruno C on va avoir un
ministre de l'Intérieur qui va quoi se
mettre en disponibilité pendant 15 jours
qui qui va répondre aux questions qui
concerne la justice j'ai dit l'intérieur
absus intéressant parce que c'est
peut-être le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
répondra à sa place à l'assemblée qui va
le ministre de la Justice qui va qui va
répondre à sa place il aura bien des
questions au gouvernement il y aura bien
des des questions de justice à à
trancher je dis pas qu'il est
indispensable he l'administration peut
fonctionner sans lui mais quand même oui
sans doute que du point de vue du
fonctionnement on va trouver sans doute
les les moyens un peu élégants de dirai
cette situation c'est dire de de de le
déporter sans sans le dire d'une
certaine manière puisque il avait été à
un moment donné on avait songé
qu'effectivement il pourrait avoir une
sorte d'intérime peut-être exercé par la
première ministre elle-même qui le qui
le remplacerait mais là c'est vrai qu'on
voit que le cooup politique serait
beaucoup plus important parce que du
coup ça envoie un message qu'il y a
vraiment un souci et que l'exécutif
pense qu'il y a vraiment un souci donc
la solution a été trouvée de le
maintenir en poste mais sans doute
qu'ils vont trouver du point de vue du
fonctionnement devant l'Assemblée
nationale et les moyens de ne pas les de
ne pas l'exposer parce que effectiv de
question au gouvernement même c'est pas
non plus ça pas mois 10 jours voilà mais
c'est vrai que c'est une situation qui
est une situation qui va être compliquée
pour lui à pour pour lui à à gérer il a
un tempérament qui est un tempérament de
combattant ça c'est très clair il l'a
montré à de nombreuses reprises dans sa
vie professionnelle et dans sa vie dans
sa vie politique donc il faut peut-être
aussi sans doute dans cette période là
en terme de communication peut-être le
protéger de lui-même aussi parce qu'il a
tempérament qui est un tempérament un
peu bouillonnant oui puis alors il a on
a fait l'hypothèse d'une condamnation
mais a aussi l'hypothèse qu'il qu'il
sortte blanchi de l'épreuve de
absolument à ce moment-là alors à ce
moment-là ça ça le renforcerait
considérablement puisque ça lui ça
ferait même monter en grade d'une
certaine manière lui qui a cette
réputation de celui qui a obtenu
tellement de tellement d'acquittement et
qui aurait du coup réussi à triompher de
de toutes les adversités politiques
alors il y a la question du soutien de
l'exécutif qui vous l'avez évoqué
Mathieu depuis plusieurs mois on écoute
sur ce thème la première ministre
Élisabeth B c'était ce matin sur France
Inter alors tout d'abord moi je voudrais
dire qu'en tant que garde des sauts Éric
Dupont maréti a toute ma confiance qui
fait un excellent travail et comme
chacun il a le droit à la présomption
d'innocence donc on s'est organisé pour
qu'il puisse à la fois assurer sa
défense et en même temps que le
ministère continue à tourner Abel m le
ministre de la justice il tient
évidemment à ce soutien vous raconterz
dans dans le portrait que vous lui
consacrez dans dans le quotidien Le
Monde une anecdote qui date du 9 octobre
dernier ça se passe dans l'avion
présidentiel c'est ça qu'est-ce que
racontez-nous oui il est en déplacement
pour Hambourg et il apprend que
Elisabeth borne a dit sur BFM TV que en
cas de condamnation il devait partir et
ça ça l' il y a plusieurs témoins qui
nous ont raconté que ça l'a énervé parce
que c'est le fait même d'évoquer la
possibilité qu'il soit qu'il soit
coupable pour lui c'est quelque chose
qui va à l'encontre de sa présempption
d'innocence et et et de tout ce qu'il
dit depuis le départ qu'il est innocent
et que il sera il en sortira blanchi
donc c'est quelque chose qui le qui qui
vraiment on le sent quand quand on
évoque ce sujet avec lui on sent qu'il y
tient à cette à cette présemption
d'innocence et c'est toute cette
conviction qu'il voudra donner devant il
le dit d'une voix suffisamment forte
pour que ce soit entendu de l'avion
c'est c'est ça exactement que ça vien au
orilles prés
ailleurs il a une voix forte oui ça
c'est vrai il a s'en servir pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron garde Éric Dupont deti
d'après vous effectivement Mathieu
parlait il y avait une possibilité assez
simple de l'exfiltrer après la
réélection du président moi l'hpothèse
que je fais c'est qu'au fond la la
personnalité la trajectoire d'Éric
Dupont mtien intéresse beaucoup Emmanuel
Macron au fond à la fois il est
d'origine modeste il est devenu une
immense
star des tribunaux de notre système
judiciaire il avait
combattu à sa manière le Front national
il a toujours voulu incarner une justice
en proximité de justiciable et c'est
vrai que Lestat les états généraux de la
justice on lui ont permis de faire un
certain nombre de propositions il a
obtenu des moyens une augmentation de
moyen relativement significative pour la
justice en terme de de de recrutement et
sans doute que le Président de la
République trouve ce profil assez
intéressant par
ailleurs sa personnalité et son approche
de la justice montre qu'il a la la les
épaules assez solides pour essayer de
tenir tête à une institution qui comme
toutes les institutions n'aime pas
beaucoup quand on commence à dire il va
falloir faire des réformes il va falloir
se se réformer ça sans doute que ça
plaît beaucoup au chefs de l'État et si
c'est un des rares poids lourds dans un
gouvernement ne pèse peu quand même non
mais il faut le dire la macronie a été
infichu depuis 6 ans de faire émerger
des fortes personnalités capables de
mener des politiques lourdes c'est pas
c'est pas juste un budget significatif
c'est le quand même faut dire qu'il a
obtenu les plus plus gros budget de
l'histoire de la 5 répuque la justice ça
dépasse cette année les 10 milliards
d'euros et et en terme de progression
sur l'ensemble des des deux kakenas ça
sera c'était nécessaire pour était
clochardisé comme disait un un de ses
précdcesseurs mais ça a été colossal et
c'est le dernier survivant de la société
civile aussi oui mais alors justement
est-ce que c'est un parce que est-ce que
c'est un ministre issu de la société
civile qui a assez vite appris la
politique d'près moi je trouve que il a
appris la politique et on l'a vu très
sur un épisode très particulier qui a
été très important pour lui sont les
émeutes cétait
cétait concomitant au remanement
ministériel c'était juste avant et
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ERC Dupont
Moretti il est allé sur le terrain il a
il s'est affiché avec une fermeté un
discours de vraiment d'une ce qu'il
appelait la réponse pénale ferme et
systématique et donc il a il a parlé des
parents des mineurs il a fait une
circulaire très rapidement pour les
procureurs et il est devenu
incontournable au moment des émeutes et
et c'est aussi une manière pour lui de
montrer qu'il a su qu'il a su apprendre
les codes de la politique et après cette
séquence de 3 qu jours c'est difficile
de l'vincer puisquil est apparu au même
titre que Géral d'Anin et que la
première ministre sur le sur le terrain
en première ligne et cetera donc
j'imagine que il l'a fait sincèrement
évidemment c'est mais il y a aussi cette
dimension de euh bah voilà vous voulez
vous vous vous voulez me me virer
essayez maintenant on va au-delà du cas
du pontoriti on va maintenant comme
promis s'intéresser à l'existence même
de la Cour de Justice de la République
je propose à Steve Dourdin de de nous
rejoindre on va faire un peu de
pédagogie grâce à grâce à Steve
rebonsoir Steve présentation voilà c'est
le point de départ de cette Cour de
Justice de la République alors vous en
avez parlé hein c'est la seule
institution qui a le pouvoir de juger
les crimes et les délits commis par les
ministres dans l'exercice de leur
fonction elle a été créée en 1993 par
une loi constitutionnelle à la suite de
l'affaire du sang contaminé elle vient
remplacer la cour la Haute Cour de
Justice l'objectif c'est de réconcilier
l'opinion publique avec les
responsabbles ble politique alors que
beaucoup à l'époque ont le sentiment que
les élus bénéficient d'une certaine
impunité pour les décisions qu'ils
prennent difficile équilibre que cette
réforme constitutionnelle Thomas car
l'idée est aussi bien de faire en sorte
que la justice n'empiète pas sur les
politiques qui sont mené par le
gouvernement peut-on lui faire confiance
à c de justice de la républiqueou
question c'est l'une des grandes
questions elle revient régulièrement
depuis depuis de nombreuses années on
rappelle qu'elle peut être saisie part
tout justiciable la CGR si vous estimez
Thomas avoir été laisé par un délit ou
un crime commis par un membre du
gouvernement vous pouvez vous tourner
vers elle il y a eu par exemple beaucoup
beaucoup de plaintes qui ont été
déposées à la suite de la crise du covid
mais c'est sa composition qui prête le
flan aux critiques elle est constituée
de 15 juges trois magistrats de la Cour
de C cassation 12 parlementaires 6
députés 6 sénateurs de tout bord les
élus qui ont la charge de juger Éric
Dupont Moretti sont connus côté député
on trouve trois élus de la majorité
présidentielle trois élus des
oppositions côté Sénat on trouve deux LR
un socialiste un sénateur horizon un
Renaissance et un centriste au total
donc trois magistrats professionnels 5
élus de la majorité et SEP élus
d'opposition alors on l'a évoqué mais
rapidement tout à l'heure cette Cour de
Justice de la République a-t-elle
facilement condamné dans le passé ben
depuis 93 on compte 10 procès au total 8
ministres et deux secrétaires d'État ont
été jugés en 30 ans c'est une
institution qui est plutôt clémente dans
les 10 procès qui ont eu lieu il y a eu
quatre a quatre condamnations avec surc
deux dispenses de peine jamais la CJR
n'a prononcé de prison ferme à
l'encontre des accusés cette clémence de
la cour suscite beaucoup de critiques
les experts considèrent qu'il faut la
réformer François Hollande le pense
Emmanuel Macron également dernier
profondeur en date les états généraux de
la justice dans un rapport remis en
juillet 2022 le comité préconise tout
simplement la suppression de la CJR
merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain pour tous
ces détails Cécile guerberg est-ce que
cette cour de justice de la République
est en surc pour vous alors elle est en
surcis depuis très longtemps elle est
même en surc depuis
1993u création voilà exactement à peine
créé les ceux qui avaient été un peu à
l'origine de sa création ont vu que ça
dysfonctionnait assez largement dans le
cadre de l'affaire du sang contaminé et
ont proposé la la suppression alors elle
n'a jamais été supprimée pour diverses
raisons qui tiennent soit parce qu'il y
avait des affaires pendantes soit
surtout c'est surtout le cas depuis un
certain nombre d'années parce que pour
la supprimer il faut réviser la
Constitution puisqu'elle est prévue par
le texte constitutionnel à l'article 68
et bien évidemment il est délicat de
réviser la
constitution de sorte que si vous
combinez ça au fait qu'il y a un certain
nombre d'affaires pendantes et votre
votre votre expert a cité les affaires
du relatives au covid où il y a
effectivement une explosion du nombre de
requêtes déposées enfin du nombre de
plaintes déposées devant la commission
des requêtes je pense qu'on est encore
avec la Cour de Justice de la République
pour un certain nombre d'années faut le
faire en tout début de quinqu d'une
certaine faç et c'était d'ailleurs dans
le projet de révision constitutionnelle
de
Macron parce que sinon sinon ça devient
impossible impossible pour ils peuvent
pas proposer la suppression de la CGR
aujourd'hui quoi bah surtout avec surout
après un cas d'école comme comme
celui-là c'est vrai quand même que sur
le les les procédures enclenchées après
la la crise covid Bruno cottres on est
on est un peu dans les dans dans les
limites du de de l'usage de la Cour de
Justice de la République c'estàdire que
B les ministres en exercice qui ont
peut-être fait des erreurs mais de là
les placé devant un tribunal
oui en même temps c'est vrai qu'il faut
bien qu'il y a un mécanisme qui permette
comme ça a été rappelé aux citoyens
justiciaablees ordinaire que nous sommes
chacun d'entre nous de pouvoir faire
appel ou de d'en faire appel à une
juridiction si on trouve qu'on est
victime de l'action d'un de membbr du
gouvernement donc il faut qu'il y ait un
mécanisme à un moment donné qui soit le
principe de la
responsabilité on peut pas expliquer au
électrices aux électeurs aux citoyens on
peut pas leur expliquer que le membre du
gouvernement est par des définition n'a
pas de compte à rendre donc ça fait
partie des mécanismes très importants de
même assez fondamentaux du bon
fonctionnement démocratique qui est
qu'on est à rendre compte de son action
et pas seulement le jour des élections
devant les électeurs mais mais mais là
on n pas enfin c'est pas une question de
détournement de fond je reste sur la
question des des plaintes lié à la crise
covid ça peut être éventuellement quoi
du un mensonge un mensonge d'État qui
pourrait être reprjet par certains
Français c'est sur quoi ça se ça se base
ah ce sont généralement des abstentions
d'agir des it de négligence c'est-à-dire
des délits involontaires et et et
j'entends bien ce que dit mon voisin en
disant voilà il faut que le justiciable
pu enfin il faut que tout un chacun on
puisse éventuellement aller devant une
juridiction pour demander à nos poli on
pe le faire pour tous les ministres en
exercice de à peu près tous les et puis
surtout le le le bon fonctionnement d'un
régime parlementaire veut que ce type
d'actes qui sont des actes de la
fonction parce que finalement qu'est-ce
qu'on se demande c'est si le ministre a
été bon ou pas s'il a pris les mesures
qu'il fallait pour traiter du covid s'il
fallait reporter ou non les élections
mun pal par exemple est-ce qu'il a été
bon ministre ou mauvais ministre ça à
mon sens ça relève de la responsabilité
politique et le lieu naturel de cette
responsabilité par politique c'est
l'Assemblée nationale éventuellement le
Sénat si vous en avez une acception plus
large moi j'ai une question sur la
composition de cette Cour de Justice de
la République d'où ça vient les les les
les 12 parlementaires parce que je vois
bien l'idée il y a untit côté justice
ordinale c'est jamais de de la vraie
bonne justice quand on se fait juger par
ces pères et est-ce qu'on peut même pas
pousser le bouchon plus loin est-ce
qu'ils sont pas en conflit d'intérêt les
députés de l'opposition précisément au
motif quiévoqué à BM c'estàd se payer un
poids lourd du pouvoir en place et puis
poussons encore plus loin j'ai vu que
dans la liste il y avait Laurence
vichnevski qui est une parlementaire
mais qui a été magistrate par le passé
est-ce qu'elle serait pas elle aussi en
conflit d'intérêt bref d'où ça vient
cette idé de composition de donner de
alors c'est cette idée ça BIA notre ça
va forcément biaiser notre perception et
celle de de l'opinion publique
complètement euh cette idée de faire
siéger des parlementaires au côté de de
magistrat professionnel en fait elle
vient à la fois d'une tradition euh
d'une tradition constitutionnel
puisqu'il y a eu à un temps vous faisiez
allusion à la Haute Cour de Justice donc
c'était des parlementaires qui jugeaient
de ça mais surtout c'est l'idée
sous-jacente selon laquelle la
responsabilité pénale devrait prendre la
suite serait un complément nécessaire à
la responsabilité politique s'inscrireer
dans la lignée de la responsabilité
politique et c'est très exactement ce
qu'on a vu c'est-à-dire que très souvent
la Cour de Justice de la République est
intervenue à postériori lorsque les
mécanismes de responsabilité politique
ne pouvaient plus jouer puisque les
ministres N était plus en fonction là où
le cas est très différent et ça a été le
même cas dans le cadre du covid c'est
que vous aviez la Cour de Justice de la
République qui était actionnée par le
biais des perquisitions et cetera alors
même que la responsabilité politique
pouvait très bien continuer à jouer donc
vous n'avez plus une substitute vous
avez véritablement une substitution de
la responsabilité pénale à la
responsabilité politique et je pense que
dans un régime parlementaire ça pose
effectivement des difficultés alors
certains parlent je vais vous donner la
parole tout de suite certains parlent
même d'anachronisme par exemple l'ancien
candidat socialiste à la présidentielle
benoî Amon qui était sur France 2 ce
matin ce qu'il faut espérer c'est que la
Cour de Justice de la République est
quand même un anachronisme he vous
demandez à des parlementaires d'être
juges alors qu'il y a évidemment même
s'il prête serement des intérêts
politiques sous-jacents moi j'attends
qu'elle dise le droit euh vous vouliez
prendre la parole la ben MRE est-ce
qu'elle est al chronique pour vous cette
à chronique je sais pas si c'est le bon
terme mais en tout cas ce qui est clair
c'est que la composition avec 12
parlementaires en son sein pose problème
parce que de toutes les manières le tout
décision est entaché de suspicion soit
elle est trop clément soit est clémentes
on se dit ah bah c'est parce que c'est
entre eux ses copains les coquins soit
elle est trop elle est trop sévère et on
se dit bah ils ont voulu se payer un
membre du gouvernement ou se venger ou
voilà donc c'est quelque chose qui qui
clairement moi pour avoir fait un papier
sur le sujet j'ai jamais vu quelque
chose qui faisait l'unanimité contre
elle comme la sgè c'est que ce soit les
universitaires que ce soit les anciens
membres de la CGR ou les mem membr
actuel qui ont témoigné personne n'est
satisfait de ce fonctionnement donc
c'est qu'il a un problème et et surtout
ce que dit Benoît amont est vrai enfin
je veux dire les politiques vont pas au
moment où ils enfilent la robe mettre
leurs conviction et leurs intérêts
partisans au vestia enfin peut-être ils
ont ils prêtent serment effectivement
mais il y a toujours quelque chose de
sous-jacent et et c'est et c'est ça
c'est cette a cette possibilité de la
suspicion qui pose vraiment problème oui
avec un autre aspect parce que quand
même
ERC duupomariti il gère l'administration
à laquelle appartiennent les trois
magistrats qui vont le juger quoi alors
c'est pas exactement leur supérieure
hiérarchie qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire
là-dessus al effectivement il y a ce
problème là qui qui est lié à ce
justiciable si et et le problème est
d'autant plus compliqué qu'à l'origine
de la plainte à l'origine de la plainte
vous avez des syndicats de magistrats
donc donc le problème en fait de de ces
espèces de de mélange des genres et de
conflit constant et et et de chaque côté
en réalité il est il est supérieur
hiérarchique du parquet général qui va
requérir contre lui he oui alors là là
oui il a quand même oui donc
potentiellement avec un petit pouvoir
lui ou ses amis politiques sur la
carrière des des uns et des autres ENF
mais mais non mais enfin on va pas non
plus être naïf c'est forcément une
question qui se pose en tout cas encore
une fois même même le réquisitoire va on
va se dire mais ce qu'il le dit pour il
vient d'arriver reméy le procureur
général il a remplacé Mollin est-ce
qu'il va re ir de façon très sévère pour
montrer qu'il est voilà exactement qu'il
est dans la ligéeance ou est-ce qu'il va
faire un réquisitoire je sais pas
équilibré et là on va se dire ah là là
il vient d'être nommé et cetera donc de
toutes les manières le fait qu'il soit
en plus le ministre de la Justice en
exercice ajoute de la complexité à une
situation déjà extrêmement complexe
Bruno C c'est c'est c'est vraiment le le
titre le thème de notre débat comment
juger un ministre de la Justice on est
quasiment dans la Mission Impossible
est-ce que vous voez ça oui oui c'est
vrai qu'on est un peu dans la Mission
Impossible on est en train de soulever
les les uns et les autres toutes les
difficultés de le toutes les difficultés
de l'exercice euh c'est vrai je je par
rapport à ce que vous disiez
effectivement que la responsabilité
pénale se substitue à la responsabilité
politique totalement si c'était le cas
ça serait effectivement très mauvais du
point deue du fonctionnement
démocratique des institutions mais
néanmoins notons que les politiques sont
globalement perçu comme très
négativement et se protégeant les uns
les autres la justice est investie d'un
faible niveau de confiance euh d'après
l'enquête que nous réalisons C vipof
toutes les années notre baromètre de
confiance politique on est un peu moins
de 50 % de confiance dans la justice
c'està-dire 25 ou 30 points de moins de
confiance dans la justice que dans la
que dans la police et globalement voilà
des institutions qui sont font qui sont
perçu par les les par les Françaises les
Français comme ne fonctionnant pas bien
comme ne répondant pas à la demande très
forte à la fois de démocratie direct de
transparence de de rendre des comptes et
rendre des comptes c'est pas au sens euh
faire rendre des comptes à quelqu'un au
sens de le mettre genoux à terre non non
c'est que les politiques et davantage de
compte à rendre sur leur action au fond
et beaucoup de Françaises et de Français
ont le sentiment que et bien ce ce ce ce
compte-rendu de l'action pratiquement
invisible oui Mathie qu est-ce que les
parlementaires jouent les juges d'une
certaine façon si je peux me permettre
il y a une instance qui qui qui
fonctionne d'ailleurs pas mal c'est la
Commission les commissions d'enquête
parlementaires et on le sait
particulièrement ici au Sénat
et ça remplit une fonction qui n'est pas
forcément de dire le droit mais en tout
cas qui est de signaler au parquet si
des choses qui qui apparaissent lors de
la dite commission parlementaire et
surtout qui politiquement là on peut
cuisiner un ministre le mettre sur le
grille le mettre face à ses
contradictions et éventuellement après
il n'a plus d'autre choix que d'en tirer
les conséquences on l'a vu dans le cas
de de mal Chapa alors qu' a été aidé
d'une certaine façon mais je dire c'est
c'est quand vous vous êtes responsable
de quelque chose qui mal passé et que ça
apparaît au grand jour dans ce cadre là
de là qui est une forme de manif
manestation de la vérité sinon sinon
judiciaire en tout cas politique et ben
ça ça pardonne pas oui vérité politique
puisque il y a pas de a pas de stion
judiciaire dans dans dans le cas
particulier alors que c'est une Guer là
on va se retrouver avec des
parlementaires enfin ça pose une
question de de séparation des pouvoirs
aussi on se retrouve avec des
parlementaires qui qui vont faire la
justice
alors pas tout à fait c'està dire que
les parlementaires ont vocation
normalement à juger de la rectitude de
l'action d'AM
mais pas nécessement en fonction du
droit pénal et de la procédure pénale
c'est là où le BAB c'estàd qu'on est
dans le mélange des genres constant et
le simple fait qu'on les voit revêtir la
robe de juge c'est quand même très très
curieux alors même les jurés d'assise ne
revê pas la robe de juge comme si le
costume allait faire deux juste
précisément des pénalistes émérites et
et des gens qui ne sont plus des
politiques par l'analogie c'est ça en
fait ça se passe un peu comme dans un
juré d'assise avec un président du
tribunal qui
cadre le débatà un michemin entre la
correctionnelle et un juris d'assise
l'analogie avec le juris d'assise c'est
plutôt qu'il y a effectivement ces jurés
parlementaires un peu à à l'image des
jurés populaires qui qui siègent au sein
au sein des cor DESC et et puis il faut
pardon vous inter il faut il faut dire
un mot on l'a évoqué de du passif ou de
la relation passée
entre er du pont Marti et les magistrats
quand même ENF ça complique encore
encore un peu plus la situation encore
ça alors c'est vrai que lui quand on lui
parle de ça il dit non mais le temps a
passé mon bilan montre que j'ai entendu
leur revendication notamment au moment
des États généraux qu'il y a un plan de
recrutement qu'il y a des des des
budgets records c'est vrai même même
l'USM qui est le principal syndicat de
magistrat le reconnaît et d'ailleurs ça
leur pose une difficulté de critiquer
duetti maintenant
euh est-ce que ça suffit à effacer la
ardoise je ne suis pas sûr parce que euh
Éric Dupont moréti quand était avocat
c'était fait une spécialité de de de de
bâtir un rapport de force lors de
l'audience de créer des incidents et
cetera et donc c'est vrai que comme il a
énormément plaidé il a eu énormément de
de problème avec certains magistrats et
c'est vrai que il a il ne jouit pas de
la meilleure réputation parmi eux mais
peut-être que le temps faisant ça s'est
aplani il dit quoi il dit qu'il l'ont
que les les difficultés c'est plutôt
avec certains syndicat magistrat
exactement il dit exactement ça il dit
c'est avec certains magistrats certains
représentants des magistrats mais pas
avec l'ensemble de la profession au
contraire ça se passe bien quand je vais
à l' nm je suis très bien accueilli
voilà et vous rappeler que le jour de sa
nomination le principal syndicat de
magistrat qui dit c'est une déclaration
de guerre oui bien sûr c'est fait mais
donc Emmanuel Macron il savait ce qu'il
faisait en nomant éc d pont moriti place
B enfin oui oui oui je pense c'est
d'ailleurs mon mon hypothèse c'est que
ce cette trajectoire cette personnalité
politique cette personnalité de d'éc
Dupont mertier intéresse le président de
la République parce que euh dans le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron depuis le début
il y a quand même l'idée de faire un peu
bouger les lignes de faire bouger des
institutions de faire bouger il s'en est
pris aussi la réforme de la haute
fonction publique par exemple le
remplacement de l'École nationale
d'administration un véritable véritable
pilier de la 5e République qui est
devenu maintenant un institut du service
public donc on voit que chez le chef de
l'État il y a cette idée de faire bouger
les lignes et d'avoir des personnalités
qui lui permettent de faire bouger les
lignes et c'est vrai que de ce point de
vuelà il savait très bien sans doute ce
qu'il faisait en Nant du piti allez on
va terminer en revoyant quand même une
image qui est symptomatique de la
tension la pression subie par Éric
dupomoriti depuis des mois on est le 7
mars dernier à l'Assemblée nationale
Olivier marlex le président du groupe LR
à l'Assemblée vient de rappeler la mise
en examen du ministre alors on a entouré
le geste et donc il y a une succession
de bras d'honneur on pensait qu'il y en
avait deux en fait on en a même compté
trois en revoyant les les les images les
images tout à l'heure le garde des sauts
qui viendra s'excuser ensuite en
affirmant d'avoir viser personne en
particulier je suis je le dis à toute la
représentation nationale profondément
affecté par ce moment que je suis amené
à vivre je redis
ici avec beaucoup de force que je n'ai
pas voulu viser le président marlex mais
si mon geste a été mal
interprété je lui présente mes excuses
ainsi qu'à toute la représentation
nationale AB m c'est assez surprenant on
a dit tout à l'heure que finalement
c'était un ministre issu de la société
civile qui avait assez vite appris les
codes de la politique oui alors ça je
suis pas sûr que ce soit dans les codes
politique les excuses le son on voit que
bon c'est pas les excuses les plus
spontanées qui existent parce que juste
avant il avait pris le micro en disant
il y a pas eu un seul un doigt d'honneur
il y en a eu trois il l'avait dit un peu
de façon bravage déjà euh mais encore
une fois c'est parce queon avait mis en
cause sa présomption c'est ce qu'il dit
hein sa présomption d'innocence c'est
que et sa défense il dit j'ai fait un
doigt d'honneur à au manque de respect à
la présomption d'innocance enfin c'est
quelque chose d'assez euh Capil tracté
comme on dit dans dans dans la presse
voilà mais c'est c'est ça c'est vrai que
c'est c'est quelque chose que
normalement un ministre ne devrait pas
faire hein euh et le fait même qu'il
soit encore en place après après ça ça
montre qu'il est quand même très soutenu
parce que ce ce cet événement arrive AR
est arrivé pardon au moment du débat sur
les retraites et la majorité avait
besoin des voix de LR donc en fait c'est
ça arrivait au pire des moments c'était
vraiment s'il y avait quelqu'un qui
faire Olivier marlex donc voilà c'était
une erreur une faute politique même
au-delà de la de l'aspect de politesse
et Cera c'était une faute politique
grave et euh et il est resté il a pas eu
de il a fait les excuses et c'est passé
Bruno cottrress est-ce que l'opinion
publique désapprouve forcément un geste
comme celui-là vous voyez ce que je veux
dire oui c'est compliqué effectivement
parce que on pourrait dire effectivement
l'opinion est choqué un membre du
gouvernement ne devrait pas faire ça il
doit être exemplaire dans ses
comportement dans ses paroles et en même
temps d'une certaine manière il est
presque lui-même l'interprète de la
représentation qu'ont les Françaises et
les Français de la de la politique et au
fond les politiciens nous font des bras
d'honneur bon ben si l'un d'entre eux
imiste dans le jeu pour leur faire un
bras d'honneur donc voilà c'est assez
c'est assez compliqué mais mais
globalement ce sont ce type de c'est ce
type de d'événement qui marque dans
l'opinion publicque je pense que
beaucoup s'en rappellent elle lui vient
d'où à BEM cette rage là cette cette
ambition de son histoire personnel aussi
oui c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
typique de de de la personne qui vient
d'un milieu modeste qui a réussi par ses
propres moyens par sa propre force et
son propre talent il a perdu son papa
très jeune il a perdu son papa très
jeune sa maman est italienne
avec un travail modeste un milieu
modeste encore une fois il il a fait
toute sa carrière dans les prêtoirs il a
il a il a su gagner en respectabilité
par son travail et donc c'est vrai que
c'est une ascenstion sociale qu'il faut
qu'il faut saluer hein effectivement et
et c'est quelque chose qui lui reste euh
comment dire très présent dans son
discours
c'est il est vraiment euh comment dire
euh TR enfin il le met en avant souvent
et c'est c'est pas forcément un artifice
c'est quelque chose qui il se considère
comme un ancien pauvre il le dit pas
comme ça mais au final c'est ça c'est un
ancien pauvre qui a réussi voilà cine
Guérin barque pour terminer ça donne
envie d'assister à la pldoirie de d'éc
duupom moriti défendant er duuporiti
voyez ce que je veux dire très
certainement mais il a des avocats il va
pas il se garder bien de surveill s
avocat qu j'imagine que la tche est
difficile mais il a pas dû prendre les
plus mauvais ou merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participer à ce à ce débat
qui était passionnant je vous dis à
bientôt sur Public Sénat et je vous
donne rendez-vous demain 18h 22h pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
noter que l'invité de la matinale
d'Oriane mansini demain il sera 8h du
matin c'est Julien Aubert le
vice-président des républicains merci à
toutes et à tous de votre fidélité belle
soirée
[Musique]